the situation in kazakhstan's largest
city amati is reported to be calm but
tense after violence this week the death
toll from the unrest remains unclear the
interior ministry says more than 5 000
people were arrested troops from a
russian-led security alliance continue
to enter the country after appeals for
help from the president and local people
are facing an uncertain future
a desperate wait for news
at an almighty morgue dozens of people
line up
many of them fear their loved ones died
on january 6
the worst day of a bloody week in
kazakhstan's largest city
another queue in almighty this one for
bread
many stores had to close during the
unrest in recent days
people are running out of food
other stores the one over there and
another further up the road has been
closed since yesterday but people need
to eat something
the government appears back in control
of downtown almaty
but days of protests and looting have
scarred the city as demonstrators let
out their anger at decades of
authoritarian rule
destroying this office of the ruling
party
the unrest frightened many in the city
some welcome the army on the streets
they restore a feeling of security to
people
give us the sense that we're on our way
out of this
the things are gradually getting back to
normal
but normality doesn't look like this
elsewhere in the city the government
continues what it calls an anti-terror
operation
it's determined to put down opposition
whether it comes from violent or
peaceful protesters
they haven't been listening to the
people as a politician once said if
there's no chance of a peaceful
revolution there'll be an armed one
as the situation worsens people rush to
flee kazakhstan
some here in the north
and many more in the south near almaty
they're frightened by the situation in
the city
one of them says
it's as if the war has already arrived
and i'm now joined by igadeem toyu
hanova an independent journalist from
kazakhstan and she joins me now from
prague a very warm welcome to the show
we've now seen thousands of protesters
arrested and thousands of mainly russian
troops sent into kazakhstan under the
collective security treaty organization
at this point our president to kiev and
his government back in control
from what i hear in almaty there are
still occasional shootings on the
streets and people are ordered to stay
at home to be safe and there is still
curfew which has moved from i think 11
pm to 8 pm
and um
i would say that overall the situation
is leaning more towards stabilizing but
it's still very dangerous to be outside
okay so moving towards stabilizing we
have seen now arrests and dismissals at
the top of kazakhstan's security
architecture including the former
security chief karim massimov are we
looking at an internal elite power
struggle here
to be honest it's a mix of everything
it's mixed with people's genuine desire
for change and political reforms it is
mixed with some internal political gain
in the highest highest echelons of power
and then there's geopolitics involved
and other things so right now it's
really confusing and it's hard to say
what exactly is going on and why
and why some people did certain things
so um i would say that
it is connected mostly with some power
struggles at the top
as well as
people's desire for change
now russia presumably doesn't want to
see ongoing pro-democracy demonstrations
in the streets i do have the sense that
the authorities will be able to maintain
order in the long term or are we likely
to see protesters return to the streets
in the coming days and weeks
i think right now
authorities are trying to
to just stabilize the situation with
shootings and violence
but i'm sure that uh people will
continue to protest if their demands are
not met and not delivered as it was
promised many years ago and um there are
many people outside of kazakhstan as
well protesting in front of embassies
and in front of different government
buildings related to kazakhstan and
so far i don't know if authorities will
change the line and i don't think they
will because if
we've heard the previous um address to
the nation of tokyo
he
was kind of threatening uh of the
further crackdown on a civil society and
independent media
and we know that some activists some
peaceful activists were detained and
arrested
and
are now in jail
now there was also speculation that the
influential former president nursal
nazarbayev had fled the country what do
we know about his whereabouts and the
role that he is playing in this
there were rumors that he fled the
country but today we had official
information from his press secretary
that he's actually in the capital and he
is in direct contact with customs tokyo
and that he asked to unite behind him to
fight these forces
so
we don't know what is true right now
because it's really confusing and it
adds confusion every day new some new
official information
but some experts in a small central
asian pool of experts think that uh
nazarbaya's power has become less
than tokyo's power now um and that's how
the power struggle is at least viewed
publicly
and yeah i don't know if it's true or
not but
uh clearly something is going on on the
top and unfortunately uh some civilians
are dying and we have
known and hurt uh some casualties on the
streets where innocent people have died
when they were just trying to get some
food products amid this chaos and
destroy the city of almighty for example
told you hanover thank you so much for
joining us on the show with that
important update
so let's bring in journalist ben eris he
is the founder of the media company bne
in tele news and has followed
developments in kazakhstan for more than
a decade a warm welcome to the show
thanks for joining us this weekend
the speed at which these demonstrations
flared up and spread across the country
is remarkable we've now seen thousands
of protesters arrested thousands of
mainly russian troops sent in to
kazakhstan
our president took tokyo and his
government now back in control
indeed it's been extraordinary this came
out of left field no one was expecting
it kazakhstan has been long one of the
most successful and stable of all the
central asian countries and yet um the
price hikes fuel for cars at the weekend
following a market reform
um
caused riots
caused demonstrations in the west of the
country and by tuesday that had spread
across the whole country and no one was
expecting that and then we saw
unprecedented huge demonstrations in al
martin the commercial capital tens of
thousands of people on the street sort
of reminiscent of ukraine and belarusia
and it ran rapidly out of control the
president immediately sacked the
government tried to blame the ministers
um he reintroduced uh subsidies for the
fuel prices and actually took the price
back to less than what they were last
week
um and it didn't work um and on
wednesday it looked like um the
government had lost control of the
situation but on that night they called
in the russians and now i just talked to
our correspondent again today in almaty
and he was out and about and he said
most people have stayed at home there's
sporadic clashes but but nothing
on a large scale and the city is calm
and the government seems to be firmly in
control
and we've also seen arrests and
dismissals at the top of kazakhstan's
security architecture including the
former security chief karim massimov how
would you interpret that
yeah there's a second story going on
here because
the politics in kazakhstan are slightly
complicated and so much as uh nazarbayev
the president the former president who's
been in charge since 1991 since the
beginning um he stepped down uh in 2019
and handed over to the new president
papaya however he didn't really step
down he remains in the background he's
the head of the national security
council he also his his loyalists were
in charge massimo in charge of the
security services and in eastern europe
in general central asia in particular
whoever runs the security service is the
seat of power that's the tool you use to
stay in power and during the process the
takayama has used them opportunistically
it seems to take full control of the con
of the country and so massimo was sacked
and as uh
nazarbayev was removed from the security
council and took kaif took over and so
now he's in charge so you could actually
read this actually as a coup of sorts
although the president stays in place
but he's taken full control he's pushed
nazibai out completely and this arrest
is very significant because uh takayev
has now put one of his own loyalists in
charge of the security services and
that's the real power now he's really in
he's really in control of the country
all right ben ares thank you so much for
joining us on dw news with that update
and let's turn our attention now to some
of the other stories making news around
the world
albanian police have used tear gas